[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
skimmag au Vélodrome de 50 ans en
Yvelines en compagnie de Laurent mazori
qui est mer adjoint de lancour et
vice-président de 50 ans en Yvelines en
charge du sport et de la préparation des
Jeux Olympiques et nous allons parler de
cet événement qui a lieu du 12 au 16
octobre prochain qui est le championnat
du monde
ucidisso de cycliste de surpiste il y
aura aussi les champignons du monde de
Para cyclisme du 20 au 23 octobre alors
Laurent c'est évidemment un événement
essentiel dans la vie du cyclisme
international alors c'est un événement
essentiel dans le civil international
mais à 50 ans en Yvelines et en France
puisque nous les accueillons nous
accueillons cet événement dans ce lieu
qui est le vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui a été
conçu pour accueillir ce grand ses
grands événements internationaux de même
que nous accueillerons dans quelques
années maintenant dans un an et demi en
2024 les Jeux Olympiques c'est un lieu
pour accueillir à la fois les événements
qui deviennent un spectacle mais aussi
surtout pour accueillir la population et
tous les aficionados de cyclisme sur
piste qui allons nous voir de l'Europe
entière et du monde du monde entier qui
va vous avez vu arriver sur exactement
mais c'est vrai que vous avez dit le mot
au-delà du sport et au-delà de la
compétition qui est formidable c'est un
spectacle absolument éblouissant oui ça
a été d'ailleurs dans les années je veux
dire depuis là le début du 20e siècle et
pendant toute une grande partie 20e
siècle le plus grand spectacle sportif
bien avant le football et bien avant le
rugby on venait y passer des journées
entières en famille on venait vraiment
passer tout son week-end et toute sa
semaine dans les vélos de Drôme alors on
en est plus là aujourd'hui mais on est
sur des épreuves qui sont très
impressionnantes il y a du bruit il y a
de l'ambiance il y a des gens qui
soutiennent leur pays qui soutiennent
leurs équipes on n'est pas obligé de
comprendre les épreuves parce que ça
nous disent c'est un petit peu compliqué
regardez les épreuves sont très simples
à suivre d'autres qui sont plus et on
est comme ça on est scotché on voit les
champions on peut quasiment les toucher
on voit l'effort physique que représente
le cyclisme sur piste et on peut en
famille passer une extraordinaire
journée en venant de national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines quand on a des
épreuves du niveau des championnats du
monde alors je vous propose d'en savoir
un peu plus sur l'organisation de ces
championnats du monde avec quelqu'un qui
connaît extrêmement bien cette
discipline puisqu'elle était trois fois
champion olympique c'est Florian
Rousseau qui aura la Fédération
française de cyclisme en charge de la
préparation des Jeux Olympiques et de
ces championnats du monde
un championnat du monde à domicile c'est
plus de motivation de la part des
athlètes et puis aussi du staff on est à
la maison ce sera le vélo de Rome des
Jeux Olympiques on est à moins de 2 ans
des jeux c'était une excellente prise de
repères pour nos athlètes certains n'ont
pas vécu les championnats du monde 2015
ici c'est une bonne répétition entre
guillemets notamment pour vivre ces
termes densité du très très haut niveau
et puis aussi pour nos staff en tout cas
de se régler et de bien se préparer pour
ce qui va nous attendre dans deux ans
il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont évolué
une réorganisation une structuration par
exemple sur l'accompagnement
scientifique à la performance il y a une
cellule recherche qui est dédiée à ça
[Musique]
aussi le côté médical et paramédical qui
a été renforcé la dimension
psychologique à la performance aussi
vivre des jeux c'est déjà très
particulier par rapport à Championnat du
Monde c'est plus plus donc on anticipe
tout ça le détail à son importance
[Musique]
on a une équipe ambitieuse audacieuse
aujourd'hui les athlètes connaissent
très très bien le vélo de Rome nos
cadres nos entraîneurs nos équipes aussi
ont l'habitude d'évoluer dans cet
environnement c'est un excellent outil
notamment de préparation au jeu
[Musique]
Florian Rousseau vient nous expliquer
l'organisation de ces championnats du
monde mais c'est vrai que vous l'avez
dit déjà en 2015 il y a eu des
championnats du monde ici dans ce dans
ce vélo brome en fait c'est un lieu qui
est maintenant fait pour accueillir les
plus grandes épreuves mondiales du
cyclisme il a été conçu comme tel il a
cette particularité d'être à la fois
pour les plus grands champions mais il a
également été conçu pour accueillir
beaucoup plus vite mais surtout pour une
pratique de ce sport en amateur et donc
à l'instar de ce que nous faisons au
Golf National est-ce que la Fédération
Française de Golf fait et bien ce lieu
accueille ici des platines de civisme
sur piste et n'importe qui peut venir il
suffit par contre de savoir faire du
vélo pour pouvoir se frotter au même à
la même difficulté que les grands
champions en toute sécurité vous avez
déjà essayé ou pas oui bien sûr
on monte facilement c'est assez
surprenant au bout de quelques minutes
je vais dire une quinzaine de minutes on
se rend compte qu'on peut assez
facilement monter assez haut tout
simplement par la force centrifuge et le
plus troublant c'est que les vélos de
cyclisme surpi c'est genre ne savent
peut-être pas n'ont pas de frein donc il
faut c'est exactement il faut arriver à
trouver le bon rythme pour pouvoir
s'arrêter et c'est probablement ce qui
est plus difficile même plus difficile
vous avez raison de faire la comparaison
avec le Golf National où il y a eu la
Ryder Cup il y aurait plus grand
chanteur ou il y aura aussi les Jeux
Olympiques il Open de France qui vient
de se dérouler et c'est vrai que
n'importe qui enfin faisait avoir un
petit niveau de jeu mais peut jouer au
golf national oui c'est ça c'est l'idée
c'est la particularité de nos
équipements et quelque part c'est ce
qu'on va retrouver aux Jeux olympiques
de 2024 les Jeux Olympiques auront lieu
ici au groupe national et sur la colline
d'Élancourt qui va être équipée et le
lendemain quasiment on pourra y faire du
VTT on pourra faire du golf et revenir
ici faire du cyclisme sur piste là où
auront lieu les Jeux Olympiques alors
c'est à la fois l'héritage et c'est en
même temps déjà disponible pour le golf
et pour le cyclisme sur piste et c'est
pas vrai de tous les sports pour vous
jouer à Roland-Garros il faut être en
péril dédié pour jouer au Parc des
Princes ou au Stade de France il faut
quand même mais c'est plutôt des des
professionnels alors ça c'est vrai donc
c'est à la fois pour le grand public et
à la fois pour les champions et pour des
champions évidemment c'est un des plus
beaux lieux
qui puissent leur être offert alors
c'est un écrin
magistral en matière de piste mais
également en matière d'équipements ce
que voit moins grand public tout ce qui
touche à la cryothérapie par rapport par
exemple à l'entraînement et puis la
proximité administrative c'est important
aussi puisque la Fédération française de
cyclisme a son siège dans ce vélo Drôme
il y a donc un contact direct pour les
équipes nationales avec ceux qui
d'habitude entre guillemets les dirigent
mais surtout les aides à accomplir leurs
résultats alors on est fasciné
évidemment par les exploits des
champions la rapidité roulent à 75 km/h
enfin c'est quand même absolument fou
derrière les exploits des champions
parce qu'évidemment il y a leur force
physique leur talent leur génie même
mais il y a aussi la science et la
technologie qui les aident et je vous
propose de voir un sujet tout à fait
passionnant sur la façon dont des
ingénieurs travaillent pour améliorer
les performances des sportifs
les JO en France à Paris ont généré en
fait des dispositifs de financement en
tout cas sur la partie scientifique et
comme les championnats du monde sont
l'occasion unique d'avoir une
compétition vraiment internationale de
référence avant les JO ça nous donne
l'occasion de faire une analyse de la
concurrence par exemple comparer des
trajectoires entre entre deux nations
là en fait sur cette machine on relève
les cotes pour s'assurer que la position
qu'on a réglé après des passages en
soufflerie pour optimiser
l'aérodynamisme et un travail avec la
tête pour qu'il maximise à la puissance
qui fournit sur son vélo que cette
position en fait elle est pas bougé
c'est un sujet complexe en fait la
position pour rouler vite à 75 km/h plus
de 90% de la Résistance en fait elle est
ce qui va beaucoup en fait augmenter
l'aéro c'est le bonhomme et suivant
comment il se pose sur son vélo on a la
chance d'avoir ici deux soufflerie à
côté de nous avec qui on travaille
S2A à Montigny et l'iate à
Saint-Cyr-l'École et il y a-t-il c'est
la soufflerie historique ou dans les
années 70-80 de nombreux cyclistes sont
venus faire des essais ici et
aujourd'hui on va un peu plus loin c'est
à dire qu'on essaye de faire de la
soufflerie réelle et donc d'analyser les
choses en situation sur le vélo de route
un formidable outil pour pour mesurer et
ça en fait les choses elles sont simples
pour pouvoir le faire pour comparer une
puissance qui est produite par l'athlète
donc sur son pédalier par exemple et la
vitesse à laquelle il évolue et ça ça
nous permet en fait de calculer des
coefficients aérodynamique ce qui se
passe en vrai en réel c'est ça notre
critère décision c'est ça le plus
important
[Musique]
on peut récolter un niveau de données
qu'on avait jusque là que en laboratoire
aujourd'hui c'est concentré dans un tout
petit boîtier là ici ça nous donne les
niveaux de force réparties pour chaque
pied quasiment chaque degré et en
l'occurrence ce capteur on l'a développé
avec l'École polytechnique donc il y a à
peu près 7 à 8 personnes
issues des grandes écoles et des
universités présents sur site pendant
les épreuves chronométrées
[Musique]
alors Laurent on va parler de
l'organisation de ce vélodrome quel est
le rôle de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors
l'agglomération 59 vin est propriétaire
à la fois du foncier mais également du
bâtiment nous l'avons acquis à travers
ce qu'on appelle un partenariat public
privé qui a été système qui a été
souvent décrié mais qui s'y est
absolument parfait puisqu'il est borné
en matière de loyer c'est à dire que
nous avons un partenaire qui a investi
et à terme d'un contrat d'une durée de
30 ans nous en serons à nouveau les
propriétaires il l'a financé et bien
entendu il y a un exploitant qui l'a mis
en place ici qui est l'UCPA qui réalise
l'ensemble des manifestations qui ont
lieu dans un Vélodrome quand il ne
s'agit pas bien entendu de manifestation
cycliste puisque dans ce cas là c'est la
Fédération Française qui fait partie du
partenariat qui reprend les droits et
qui organise ces événements et qui a son
siège ici comme vous le rappeliez
exactement alors on parlait évidemment
des championnats de cyclistes mais ce
qui va évidemment tous les grand
événements de cyclisme se passe ici mais
il y a d'autres sports qui se font au
Vélodrome bien sûr l'objectif de la
création de ce bâtiment ça va au-delà
effectivement du cyclisme c'est de
pouvoir l'ouvrir au maximum aux
habitants et à beaucoup de disciplines
on y pratique de la zumba on est
pratique du badminton
on y a très souvent un certain nombre de
réunions très importants d'entreprises
du secteur il y a le sport et il y a pas
que le sport absolument il y a les
entreprises qui se réunissent ici qui
sont des sourds on a eu récemment le Big
tour effectivement et donc c'est
l'avantage d'avoir un lieu comme
celui-là d'avoir une telle superficie
dans son air central qui permet d'y
faire quasiment tout on y a fait par
exemple des matchs de basket également
des matchs de handball féminins de
national de 1 de première division voilà
donc tout cela permet c'est un
équipement qui est c'est pratiquement
une Arena et il y a eu évidemment tout
le monde s'en souvient le vaccino drone
qui était l'un des plus grands français
on aurait aimé pouvoir se passer cette
activité mais ça a été effectivement le
plus gros le plus grand vaccinodrome
français avec plus de 400 000
vaccinations à tout moment il peut
resservir mais j'espère que cette année
et dans les années à venir il ne servira
plus à cela mais oui il a été une
efficacité extraordinaire et sa
structure même et son positionnement a
permis de vacciner la totalité de la
population de 50 villes et ils l'ont
partie de la banlieue parisienne
absolument alors je vous proposerai
retrouver Nicolas André qui est le
directeur des événements à la Fédération
française de cyclisme qui va nous parler
de l'organisation de ces championnats du
monde et puis peut-être aussi du rôle
que pourrait jouer la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme dans les prochains
jeux olympiques on le regarde
[Musique]
on a hâte d'accueillir le monde entier
dans ce vélo Drôme national plus de 45
nations seront présentes 400 athlètes et
on a essayé de capitaliser sur l'édition
2015 on a optimisé les flux la sécurité
la billetterie avec une vente placée qui
connaît un franc succès aujourd'hui et
aussi en ressources humaines puisque la
responsable des épreuves sur pistes et
la même qu'en 2015 et on espère lui voir
confier les épreuves sur piste des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 à la fois pour les
valides mais aussi pour le paralympique
dans l'organisation de ces Championnats
du Monde 2022 on s'appuie sur des
bénévoles ils seront sans chaque jour à
œuvrer à nos côtés pour livrer
l'événement on aura que d'en garder
certains spécifiques sur la discipline
piste une cinquantaine environ auront la
chance d'être proposés par la Fédération
française auprès du comité
d'organisation de Paris 2024
ces Championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste sont très observées notamment
par une mission d'observation du comité
d'organisation des Jeux de Paris 2024 et
on a à cœur de prouver qu'on est en
capacité d'organiser des beaux
championnats du monde et du coup des
belles épreuves surpuissent pour les
jeux de paris 204
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors Nicolas André est évoqué des Jeux
Olympiques évidemment on suppose que le
comité olympique va regarder de près ces
championnats du monde donc c'est
important et pour vous et pour le vélo
Drôme ah oui tout à fait c'est un petit
peu un Test Event j'allais dire mais on
en a déjà fait en 2015 donc on est assez
serein on va voir grandeur nature
effectivement une configuration
équivalente à celle des Jeux olympiques
de 2024 avec autant de monde sur la
piste mais également autant de monde
dans la salle et un mot peut-être pour
conclure parce que Saint-Quentin va être
des grands lieux des Jeux Olympiques
vous êtes prêts alors oui oui on est
prêt en réalité on a une chance
extraordinaire c'est que nous avons déjà
et bien nous venons de voir le vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
qui est fonctionnel le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin Yvelines qui a accueilli à
la fois un grand nombre d'Open de France
mais également très récemment la Ryder
Cup nous allons construire et bâtir la
colline d'Élancourt alors la colline
existe elle va être équipée pour
accueillir les épreuves de VTT et nous
avons tout à côté d'ici le le Stadium de
BMX qui est également déjà fonctionnel
et puis nous aurons une cinquième
épreuve un petit peu la cerise sur le
gâteau c'est le passage des épreuves de
cyclisme sur route qui passeront dans
tout ça quand on Yvelines et que la
population pour avoir sans problématique
de billets puisque évidemment le nombre
de billets est compté vous vous en
doutez et il faudra donc il faut déjà
d'ailleurs vous rendre très rapidement
sur les sites pour commencer à faire vos
premières réservations alors sur mauvais
jeu de mots on peut dire que tout roule
absolument tout roule et sa swigg aussi
et ça se fait aussi merci beaucoup
Laurent Majorie et merci à vous et à
très bientôt pour un nouveau numéro de
ski mag
[Musique]